that dogs like you called my mama what
the net just can't get enough of this
real life dr. Dolittle Rudy's attempt to
chat with a dozen different dogs has
already been viewed over six million
times that is one of the more
intelligent conversations that you see
on the Internet
to all the dogs out there I just like to
say woof we've hooked up with Rudy and
his buddy you say Ahonen to find out how
the pair came up with the idea the idea
for the video came from I think after I
did the magic for dogs so I was just
wondering what they react to Rudy
because I knew that Rudy spoke dogs so
good I learned the barking language when
I was a kid I think I was like 10 years
old the basic bark barking sound is made
with word Roop you can try that at home
just a roof and then you say it in words
Rudy maybe fooling around but can't a
man really talk with dogs he isn't
speaking dog language dogs don't have a
language per se it's more that they
change the pitch length and frequency of
their barks to communicate emotions a
long deep bark is used when dogs are
threatened or scared compared to a short
high-pitched bark when dogs are happier
excited
Rudy's bark is short and high-pitched so
he's trying to come across as happy and
playful but not every dog responds to
this the same way sally responds by
whining with her ears back and she walks
away this is a sure sign of submission
also on the other hand totally ignores
Rudy and seems much more interested in
the cameras the dogs different responses
to Rudy could be a result of their
different breeds or Rudy's different
body positions when he's making the
barks it may also be a product of the
different dog's intelligence and
experience they're all familiar with
humans but they're not expecting one to
bark at them it turns out that dogs are
a lot like humor
if a stranger tries to talk to you do
you stick around and chatter do you walk
away well it depends on what they say
how they look and whether or not they're
posing a threat dogs and humans are all
going to be different it's a universal
language the barking so it doesn't
matter where I go so I can talk with the
dog so you understand like an Italian
dog for itself yeah yeah that's amazing
I didn't know that
you